Speaker 1: You guys know that phrase.
When it rains, it pours.
It just won't stop pouring for Donald Trump's
former lawyer, Rudy Giuliani.
There's a new report that Rudy Giuliani reportedly
called an Arizona official about getting the
election challenge, quote, fixed up so that
Donald Trump would win Arizona back during
the 2020 election.
Now, remember that flipping Arizona alone
would not have given Donald Trump the presidency
anyway.
Remember that Rudy Giuliani is already under
a major investigation.
His home and his office were raided just a
few weeks ago.
And now this.
The Arizona Republic revealed on Sunday that
Rudy Giuliani called the Maricopa County supervisor,
Bill Gates, not the Microsoft guy, just a
guy with the same name on Christmas Eve of
2020 to introduce himself as the lawyer for
Donald Trump.
He left an incredible message.
It's almost mafia like about getting this
situation resolved for everybody.
Check out this quote.
The Arizona newspaper obtained the audio and
published a transcript.
Rudy left a message saying, quote, Bill, it's
Rudy Giuliani, President Trump's lawyer.
If you get a chance, would you please give
me a call?
I have a few things, a few things I'd like
to talk over with you.
Maybe we can get this thing fixed up.
You know, I really think it's a shame that
Republicans sort of are both in this kind
of situation.
And I think there may be a nice way to resolve
this for everybody.
Why does every Rudy Giuliani quote throughout
this entire thing sound like something you'd
expect to hear on The Sopranos?
Not from the lawyer to a sitting president
of the United States?
The difference is, I would imagine that a
real mobster wouldn't leave a message like
this on a phone with their real name and speaking
so explicitly about what it is that they want.
It would be, you know, someone shows up at
the house of this Maricopa County supervisor
and says, hey, our friend in DC says he wants
to talk about the Arizona thing and get it
fixed up.
You understand?
But no, Rudy just does it.
He does it without any hesitation.
He just does it via voicemail.
And Gates has since been asked about the voicemail
and said, I never returned Rudy's call explaining
that, quote, We don't do what is easy.
We do what is right.
What's scary about that is the implication
that it would have been easy to just flip
the results and give the state to Trump.
I hope that's not what Supervisor Gates actually
means here.
Now, many of you have been emailing me regularly
saying, how is Rudy not in jail already?
There are many answers to that question.
The first is people like Rudy don't tend to
go to jail.
We have a two tiered justice system and people
like Rudy tend not to end up in jail or in
prison.
Second is that the investigation that's currently
ongoing was significantly obstructed by Trump
appointees to the Justice Department when
Trump was president.
They are now coming out and saying Biden got
Rudy's home and office raided.
No, actually, the investigation started when
Trump was still president and they tried to
get a search warrant all the way back then.
But Trump appointees in the Justice Department
obstructed it and blocked it and prevented
it from happening.
So this all would have happened under Trump
had Trump's loyalists in the Justice Department
not interfered.
And third, I just don't think Rudy Giuliani's
going to prison, period.
And whenever I say that people are angry or
people say, David, you should at least optimistically
say, let's hope Rudy goes to prison, OK?
If Rudy committed crimes for which he is found
guilty, I hope he's given prison time.
That would be a that would be just after everything
that he's been involved in.
I don't believe Rudy is going to prison.
I don't believe Trump is going to prison.
And so I'm not going to gaslight you and tell
you that I think that that's a realistic possibility,
that that's just what it is.
If you disagree, if you think that there's
some real way that Rudy Giuliani ends up in
prison.
And to be perfectly frank, even if Rudy is
charged and doesn't plead out and is found
guilty at Rudy's age and for this type of
crime, I think that once you get to sentencing,
he doesn't get sent to prison anyway, even
with multiple guilty verdicts.
I just don't see it.
OK, if you disagree, let me know.
And we're going to have more coverage of this
on The David Pakman Show Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show.
If you want to see a really wacky and I mean
weaponized hate mail that I received last
night.
Find it on my personal Instagram David Pakman.
All right, quick break.
Right back after this